[Música]
bienvenidos a francia enfocó su cita con
la actualidad francesa por las pantallas
de france 24 y estamos en medio de la
naturaleza para hablar de una energía
que está siendo muy estimulado en france
en el contexto de guerra nuclear y
crisis climática el hidrógeno verde
conoceremos sus usos sobre todo en el
transporte y hablaremos con las ongs que
son más bien críticas al auge de esta
energía
[Música]
el hidrógeno verde se obtiene separando
la molécula de agua en hidrógeno y
oxígeno utilizando electricidad para que
sea verde esta electricidad tiene que
venir de fuentes renovables ya sea
energía eólica o energía solar eso hace
que aún su precio sea más caro que el de
las energías fósiles sin embargo los
expertos dicen que la cadena se está
volviendo cada vez más eficiente hace
cinco años que parís dedica un salón
para analizar las posibilidades de esta
energía francia en foco estuvo allí
además de ser azul y estar pintado con
nubes el taxi de nabil no hace ruido y
sus clientes se dan cuenta rápidamente
al menos son electricidad hype es una
empresa pionera de la movilidad con
hidrógeno verde en parís es decir aquel
que se obtiene descomponiendo la
molécula de agua con electricidad
obtenida de fuentes renovables
comenzaron con 100 autos en 2015 y hoy
el proyecto sigue creciendo esperan
tener 40 mil coches y 26 estaciones de
carga en 2024 obtenemos todas las
ventajas del eléctrico es decir no
contaminamos no hacemos ruido y tenemos
vibración pero además no tenemos los
inconvenientes del auto eléctrico a
batería ya que no tenemos problemas de
autonomía son autos con una autonomía
clásica de 500 a 700 kilómetros y sobre
todo es bueno usarlos como taxi llenamos
el tanque en algunos minutos como si
fuera un coche térmico tradicional hi
evolution es un salón que hace cinco
años despliega alfombra azul al
hidrógeno ya quienes quieren invertir en
esta prometedora energía autos de
carrera grandes camiones y hasta
bicicletas francia está apostando con
toda la producción y utilización de esta
energía sobre todo en el contexto guerra
y crisis climática el plan de lance
presentado en septiembre del 2020 para
impulsar la transición ecológica destina
7 mil millones de euros para el
desarrollo de electrolizadores que
producen el hidrógeno pero además la
comisión europea presentó en marzo ry
power su plan para emanciparse del gas
ruso que duplica los objetivos de
producción del hidrógeno verde fijados
hace dos años
en francia el sector del hidrógeno
representa un poco menos de 500 empresas
grandes como en total energy early kuyt
que van a producir hidrógeno o
almacenarlo entre el productor y el
cliente final el hidrógeno hecho de
energías renovables o no siempre que sea
bajo carbono es muy positivo por eso hay
tantas empresas hoy en francia grandes
son pequeñas que producen o quieren
producir localmente soluciones pero
también ir al extranjero y producir
hidrógeno bajo carbono es un precio
menor y luego quizás importarlo a
francia
el único freno al hidrógeno verde su
alto precio por eso chile el país
sudamericano decidió participar del
salón para posicionarse como productor
mundial de hidrógeno verde a bajo costo
chile por ser un país tan largo tenemos
distintos tipos de recursos en el norte
tenemos la mejor radiación del mundo y
eso nos permite tener un precio base de
producción de hidrógeno muy competitivo
e incluso ser competitivo si uno de los
fuerte europa llegarás a una psico
empresa también competitiva en el sur
hemos descubierto unos vientos en la
patagonia en los vientos maravillosas
que nos dan una capacidad de planta muy
parecida incluso superior algunas veces
a la capacidad que tienen los los
parques eólicos que están en el mar del
norte en esta carrera no está solo india
marruecos australia y hasta namibia que
produce el hidrógeno más barato del
mundo tienen el mismo objetivo tomando
ventaja el país sudamericano propuesto
organizar la próxima edición deja
evolution en tierras chilenas
el sol el viento son energías que se
obtienen de manera irregular por eso me
drogué no verde sirve también para
almacenar electricidad una más limpia y
menos polémica que la que producen
reactores como el que ustedes ven a mis
espaldas en francia la piel hidrógeno se
está usando sobre todo la industria
pesada para reducir sus emisiones pero
también en los transportes
la energía nuclear el corazón artificial
el tren de alta velocidad
francia quiere seguir a la cabeza de los
avances científicos así lo declaró el
año pasado y manuel macrón al presentar
su plan de relanzamiento de la economía
tras el cob y el quinto objetivo es
producir en francia- antes del 2030 el
primer avión bajo en emisiones de
carbono creo que es realizable los
expertos me dijeron nunca antes de 2035
pero también me dijeron nunca veremos
pequeños lanzadores de satélites y hace
un año dijeron que nunca tendríamos una
vacuna creo que estoy siendo un poco
pesimista diciendo 2030
efectivamente el avión hidrógeno verde
parece cada vez más real y menos un
sueño las fechas ya han sido fijadas
2024 para el test en un airbus a380 y
2035 para el estreno de este avión que
podría por primera vez volar sin
contaminar una revolución para una
industria responsable del 1,5 por ciento
de las emisiones globales una de las
dudas que debe resolver hervás es la
manera en que utilizará ese hidrógeno
no diré que es un sueño pero hace soñar
a muchos ingenieros y hoy tengo la
suerte de participar en este proyecto la
idea es reemplazar el combustible con
hidrógeno almacenado en un tanque
líquido y luego tenemos diferentes
posibilidades ya sea hacer una
conversión de hidrógeno como se hace con
el petróleo o usar una pila de
combustible para producir electricidad y
lograr una electrificación del avión con
motores eléctricos
y la explicación de las eléctricas
las pilas de hidrógeno o de combustión
las produce hace 20 años el lyon el
hidrógeno almacenado en estas celdas se
pone en contacto con el oxígeno y genera
electricidad en el proceso se elimina
agua la vela combustible es mejor que la
batería eléctrica sobre todo para los
cursos de alta potencia porque cuando
usted se pasa a algunas centenas o miles
de caballos de fuerza la batería del
vehículo es cada vez más grande y el
vehículo sólo va a servir para
transportar una batería las pilas de
combustible permiten superar este
problema la más potencia y autonomía en
un sistema más compacto y ligero que las
baterías
el león es una filial del grupo de
ferrocarriles francesa alstom aunque
parezca increíble aún un 50 por ciento
de los trenes en francia funciona con
diesel por lo que la pila de hidrógeno
comenzará a ser instalada de los
ferrocarriles para reducir también la
huella carbono de esta industria que
espera lograr la neutralidad dentro de
13 años
las ongs medioambientalistas son más
bien críticas a este auge del hidrógeno
verde françoise hardy es responsable de
las campañas océano y petróleo en
greenpeace francia para el el hidrógeno
verde no es una solución mágica contra
el calentamiento global y la verdadera
salida a la crisis pasa por un cambio en
nuestro actual sistema de producción y
consumo françois porque el hidrógeno
verde está tan de moda porque el
gobierno de francia y la unión europea
destinan sumas millonarias para
desarrollar esta energía
bendigo este libro escuchamos a la
comisión europea al gobierno francés y a
los industriales como si en la lucha
contra el cambio climático o en la
transición energética el hidrógeno fuera
responder a todas las necesidades y
fuera la solución técnica mágica que
evitaría ponerse en preguntas más
políticas y eso es lo que hay que mirar
más adelante en algunos casos el
hidrógeno y sobre todo el verde puede
responder a las necesidades en una
transición en otros casos es una
pantalla de humo que esconde el rechazo
a cambiar completamente de sistemas
françois es el hidrógeno verde una
alternativa para reducir las emisiones
de co2
el hidrógeno producido con paneles
solares y otras fuentes renovables es
una solución interesante por ejemplo
para almacenar electricidad o para mover
algunos vehículos sobre todo pesados
pero no va a reemplazar al petróleo lo
que va a reemplazar el petróleo son las
energías renovables y la seguridad es
decir menos autos repensar los
transportes públicos aislar las casas
más que consumir gas esas son las
primeras soluciones después al margen
hay que hacerse la pregunta sobre el
hidrógeno
en el contexto actual de guerra en
ucrania con la dificultad cada vez mayor
para obtener petróleo y gas de rusia
debido a las sanciones de occidente
es el hidrógeno verde una alternativa
si uno se cuestiona sobre cuáles son las
alternativas para los hidrocarburos
rusos como el gas el petróleo debido a
la crisis en ucrania hay un problema la
temporalidad pues los embargos son
impuestos ahora y es en los meses a
venir que hay que buscar otra solución y
sobre todo el fondo el problema es que
no vamos a poner hidrógeno en nuestros
autos por lo tanto para el tema del auto
la solución es que haya menos coches más
seguridad y el paso más rápido posible a
la movilidad eléctrica y en el caso del
gas que en francia se usa sólo para la
calefacción a diferencia del resto de
europa donde se usa también para
producir electricidad
la respuesta es nuevamente la seguridad
el aislamiento de los departamentos y
los edificios y la producción de energía
y calor alternativo como las bombas de
calor y en general todos los sistemas
solares de producción de calor
el gobierno francés creó un consejo del
hidrógeno hace algunos años que está
formado por grandes multinacionales de
la energía esto es una razón justamente
para desconfiar de este consejo y de las
iniciativas que el impulsa
la especificidad de francia es que es un
país con energía nuclear con el
hidrógeno no hay que equivocarse de
color el verde que es durable y que no
tiene un impacto en el medio ambiente es
producido con superávits de energías
renovables pero los que propone manuel
macro es un hidrógeno que no es verde
sino que más bien se parece al eco
blanqueo porque en realidad se trata de
producir hidrógeno con electricidad
nuclear y eso permitiría justificar la
estrategia del actual presidente de
construir más reactores cuando son una
amenaza para la humanidad que dura
millones de años
muchas gracias por la entrevista con
france 24
y hasta aquí este capítulo de francia-
enfocó muchas gracias por habernos
acompañado y hasta una próxima por las
pantallas de france 24 y entre 64 punto
com
[Música]